der am Silvester morgen im Alter von 95
Jahren gestorben ist
seitdem Morgenstunden fühlt sich der
Petersplatz hier in Rom noch in leichten
Nebel gehüllt in etwa 30 Minuten beginnt
hier das Requiem die Totenmesse für den
Verstorbenen Pontifex auf dem Platz
heute natürlich viele Gläubige aus
Deutschland aus Bayern darunter 200
bayerische Gebirgsschützen sie sind in
die Ewige Stadt gekommen um dem
verstorbenen Papst Benedikt im 16 die
letzte Ehre zu erweisen
vor wenigen Minuten wurde der schlichte
zypressenholzsarg in den der Leichnam
Benedikts gestern Abend gelegt wurde
aus dem Petersdom heraus auf den
Petersplatz getragen
und für das Requiem schließlich vor dem
Hauptaltar aufgestellt
[Musik]
und damit einen schönen guten Morgen
liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
herzlich willkommen aus Rom Deutschland
Europa ja die ganze Welt schaut heute in
und auf die ewige Stadt wo ein Mann zu
Grabe getragen wird der
Kirchengeschichte geschrieben hat
benedikt der 16 der erste deutsche auf
dem Stuhl Petri seit fast 500 Jahren und
der zweite Pontifex überhaupt der
freiwillig sein Amt aufgegeben hat von
ihm werden sich heute etwa 60.000
Menschen hier auf dem Petersplatz
verabschieden und wir kommentieren das
Geschehen von der Pressetribüne aus am
Fuße des Petersplatzes gelegen wo sich
viele Fernsehstationen aufgestellt haben
und da stehe ich nicht alleine sondern
gemeinsam mit dem Leiter der
katholischen kirchenredaktion im ZDF
Jürgen Erbacher Bongiorno guten Morgen
es ist 17 Jahre her dass der Vatikan ein
Papst für gräbnis dieser Art erlebt hat
das war nämlich die Beisetzung von
Johannes Paul dem zweiten 2005 damals
etwa eine Million Menschen in der Stadt
gemessen daran wie groß wird das heute
es wird kleiner das hat aber glaube ich
verschiedene Gründe zum einen es ist ja
schon angeklungen benedikt der 16 ist
seit knapp 10 Jahren emeritiert das
heißt sein Pontifikat liegt lange zurück
und viele Dinge die er getan hat sind
auch für die Menschen nicht mehr ganz so
präsent das zweite ist die katholische
Kirche ist an vielen Stellen in der Welt
in der Krise das muss auch Frank Papst
franziskus der amtierende in den letzten
Monaten immer wieder erfahren es kommen
nicht mehr so viele Menschen zu den
Veranstaltungen und ich glaube zum
dritten wirkt auch nach wie vor die
Pandemie noch nach auf der anderen Seite
wenn man sich die Zahlen anschaut du
hast gesagt 60.000 Menschen dreieinhalb
tausend Priester 400 Bischöfe erwartete
der Vatikan also es ist doch eine glaube
ich stattliche Zahl die hier gekommen
ist zum Abschied zu nehmen ein kleinerer
Rahmen als vor 17 Jahren aber dennoch an
der stattliche Zahl und der Vatikan hat
gestern noch einmal betont dass auch
Benedikt XVI wenngleich ihr im irritiert
war wie ein bis zuletzt amtierender
Papst beigesetzt wird mit kleinen
Unterschieden dazu gehört auch die
sargprozession die sich vor wenigen
Minuten hier auf dem Petersplatz
ereignet hat und von der wir gleich noch
einmal Bilder zeigen können als der
Zypressenholz sagt übrigens aus dem
gleichen Holz geschnitzt wie damals auch
bei Johannes Paul dem zweiten hier aus
dem Petersdom auf den sogenannten
Sagrado diesen treppenähnlichen Vorplatz
vor der Basilika getragen wurde und dann
in einer Schleife schließlich vor dem
Hauptaltar aufgestellt wurde mit
Benedikt im 16 wird ja zum ersten Mal
seit Jahrhunderten ein emeritierter
Papst zu Grabe getragen gibt es dafür
überhaupt einen festgefügtes Protokoll
oder mussten die zeremonare sozusagen
ein bisschen improvisieren
für den Vatikan ist das Neuland ähnlich
wie der Rücktritt 2013 deshalb hat man
gemerkt dass sie sich in den letzten
Tagen so Schritt für Schritt
vorangetastet haben einerseits muss
deutlich werden hier wird ein Papst
begraben andererseits muss deutlich
werden der Papst lebt er regiert er ist
voll im Amt und ich glaube insgesamt
kann man jetzt erst mit dem Tod des
Emeritus sagen ist dieses Projekt
Rücktritt überhaupt geglückt kann es
überhaupt einen Rücktritt geben jetzt
vom Ende her wird sowas möglich und
vielleicht wird jetzt dann auch möglich
dass man Regeln für so eine für so eine
Person Vorgehen findet deshalb ist
glaube ich jetzt dieser Akt noch mal
ganz wichtig und für den vatikane ganz
ziehen ganz sensible Sache eine große
Parallele zwischen Benedikt und
amtierenden Päpsten ist die Tatsache
dass auch Benedikt aufgebaut wurde im
Petersdorf und zwar drei Tage lang von
Montag früh bis gestern Abend war er im
Petersdom aufgebaut knapp 200.000
Menschen haben die Gelegenheit
wahrgenommen haben sich persönlich vom
Papa imeritos verabschiedet ja während
vor und hinter den Mauern das Vatikans
die Vorbereitungen für die heutigen
Trauerfeierlichkeiten liefen Annette
hilsenbeck über Rom in einem sagen wir
mal kleinen Ausnahmezustand
Trauer und Anteilnahme spiegeln sich in
den Gesichtern derer die in den letzten
Tagen zum Teil stundenlang in der
Schlange stehen um sich von Benedikt dem
16 persönlich verabschieden zu können
drei Tage lang hatten die Menschen dazu
Gelegenheit war der emeritierte Papst im
Petersdom aufgebaut der Tod Benedikt
geht viel nahe ihr Besuch oft eine
Herzensangelegenheit
ich bin kurzfristig nach Rom gefahren
weil Papst Benedikt eine große
Persönlichkeit war und ich will damit
einfach auch meine Anteilnahme zum
Ausdruck bringen
er hat die Kirche unterstützt unerwa
stark auch in schwierigen Phasen deshalb
ist der Beispiel für uns und eine
Ermutigung immer weiterzumachen
wir sind sehr dankbar dass wir in diesen
Tagen auch hier sind weil wir Ihnen auch
sehr schätzen als geistlichen als
Theologen als Menschen der uns auch
jeden auf seine Art ein Stück geprägt
und begleitet hat in der
deutschsprachigen Kirchengemeinde Santa
Maria der lanima ein Gemälde Benedikt
dass dieser ihnen am Anfang seines
Pontifikates schenkte nun kommen die
Gemeinde Mitglieder um vor seinem
Bildnis Kerzen anzuzünden und zu beten
man war sich besonders verbunden
es sind ganz viele die sich bei uns
jetzt melden die Erinnerung Teil
Erinnerungen teilen wollen wir haben
hier diese kleine erinnerungsstelle
aufgebaut wir merken das ganz viele
Menschen kommen auch aus den
verschiedensten Ländern auch sehr viel
junge Leute die einfach auch so einen
Moment des inneren danke sagens hier bei
uns erhalten
die souvenir-händler nahe des
Petersplatzes haben ihr Angebot in
Erwartung der Gläubigen die zum
Trauergottesdienst kommen aufgestockt
auch hier überwiegt vor allem die
Anteilnahme
menschlicher Ebene tut es uns leid er
ist immer noch ein wichtiger Papst ein
großer Theologe
in Rom verabschiedet man sich nun vom
emeritierten Papst Benedikt dem 16 der
Vatikan rechnet mit bis zu 60.000
Menschen auf dem Petersplatz
ja jetzt noch knapp 20 Minuten bis zum
Beginn des Gottesdienstes geleitet von
Papst franziskus fast alle deutschen
Bischöfe sind ja angereist haben weiter
vorne in der Nähe des Hauptaltares Platz
genommen auch die Ehrengäste die
Staatsgäste weiter vorne in der Nähe des
da Grado während meine Kollegin Annette
hilsenweg weiter hinten auf dem
Petersplatz mit Gläubigen aus
Deutschland sprechen konnte Annette wie
ist denn die Atmosphäre im Moment auf
dem Platz
die Gläubigen sind schon am frühen
Morgen hier auf dem Petersplatz gekommen
natürlich hat man versucht seinen Platz
zu bekommen möglichst nah dabei zu sein
wenn hier Abschied gefeiert wird von
Benedikt dem 16
es sind noch immer Menschen die hier an
den Eingängen warten darauf eingelassen
zu werden aber die Rituale haben ja wie
wir hören schon begonnen es war vorher
ein viel stimmiges vielsprachiges
Stimmen Gemurmel was hier herrschte eine
eher andächtige Stimme Stille und
Stimmung und das liegt natürlich daran
dass Menschen aus aller Welt hierher
gekommen sind natürlich auch aus
Deutschland und insbesondere aus Bayern
so ist hat das Bayerische Pilgerbüro
drei Busse zusätzlich geschafft hat
damit Gläubige hierher kommen können und
aus Benedikt
Heimatort Pentling ist eine besonders
große Delegation hierher kommen gekommen
mit freiwilliger Feuerwehr und
Kirchenchor auch die bayerischen
Gebirgsschützen haben 200 Mann
mitgebracht sie haben Benedikt ja
mehrfach besucht er war ja auch 20 Jahre
lang Ehrenmitglied einer Division sie
haben ihn mehrfach besucht zuletzt im
April wo er schon sehr gebrechlich war
wie es hieß aber immer noch wach und
sehr interessiert an den Geschehen aus
der Heimat
[Musik]
so die Atmosphäre auf dem Petersplatz
kurz vor Beginn des Requiems für
Benedikt den 16 der ja acht Jahre lang
Oberhaupt der katholischen Kirche
gewesen ist das ist gemessen an seinem
direkten Vorgänger Johannes Paul II
nicht viel aber Josef Ratzinger war bei
seiner Wahl zum Papst ja auch schon 78
Jahre alt und so zeichnete sich bereits
damals ab dass der deutsche er ein
übergangspaps werden würde dennoch
Benedikt hat den Kurs an der Kirche
entscheidend
er werde ja nun bald vor dem endgültigen
Richter seines Lebens stehen als sein
treuer Begleiter georg genzw war ein
Anfang 2022 diese Zeilen zum Missbrauch
Skandal vorträgt weil es der hochbetagte
Benedikt im eritus selbst gesundheitlich
nicht mehr kann klingt es wie ein
geistiges Testament
dunkle Schatten hatte das Münchner
missbrauchsgutachten auf das Wirken
Josef Ratzingers geworfen die
Vergangenheit holte ihn einen langen
nach seinem Rückzug als Papst Benedikt
der 16 dem wohl mutigsten Schritt seines
Pontifikats das am 19 April 2005 begann
ein Deutscher auf dem Stuhl Petri
geboren 1927 in Marktl am Inn
in Freising beginnt seine geistliche
Laufbahn hier wird er 1951 zum Priester
geweiht gemeinsam mit seinem Bruder
Georg
[Musik]
als Theologieprofessor macht der
schnellkarriere wird später erzbischer
von München und Freising
der Gang von hier in die Ewige Stadt sei
ihm nach eigenen Worten schwer gefallen
Johannes Paul II macht ihn zum perfekten
der Glaubenskongregation auch als Papst
bleibt der Theologieprofessor und doch
kann er begeistern Jubel beim
Weltjugendtag in Köln und auch bei
seiner Reise in die bayerische Heimat
eine theologische Vorlesung in
Regensburg jedoch wird zu schweren
diplomatischen Krise ein Zitat über den
Islam empört die muslimische Welt
auch die Begnadigung der Bischöfe der
Pius-Bruderschaft wird zum Skandal als
Holocaustleugnung in Williamsons bekannt
werden der Papst gesteht Fehler ein
fühlt sich missverstanden
während seines Pontifikats sitzt er
stets auf Aussöhnung und Dialog mit dem
Judentum besucht das ehemalige
Vernichtungslager in Auschwitz
in Israel die Gedenkstätte ja verschem
er verurteilte jede Leugnung oder
Relativierung des Holocaust
zu einer der größten Herausforderungen
wird der Umgang mit sexualisierter
Gewalt in der katholischen Kirche
systemisches Versagen zeichnet sich ab
weltweit Benedikt empfindet tiefes
Mitgefühl Charme und Bedauern über jeden
einzelnen Fall doch das geht viel nicht
weit genug zu lange habe die Kirche
weggesehen mehr Täter als Opfer
geschützt
seinen überraschenden Rücktritt im
Februar 2013 begründete er mit
schwindenden Kräften Gerüchte über
Intrigen im Vatikan die war die
leaksaffäre all das ließ er zurück als
er sich am 28 Februar 2013 per
Hubschrauber nach castellgerndorf begab
ich bin einfach nur noch ein Pilger der
die letzte Phase seiner Pilgerreise auf
dieser Erde antreten sagte er
zurück
mit diesen Worten verabschiedete sich
benedikt der 16 von den Gläubigen denn
der Mann der als Josef Ratzinger aus
Marktl am war blieb bis zu seinem
irdischen Ende im vatikanischen Exil
hochbetagt und gebrechlich reist er noch
einmal nach Deutschland um Abschied zu
nehmen von seinem älteren Bruder Georg
und von seiner bayerischen Heimat damit
ging für Joseph Ratzinger vor seinem
eigenen Abschied noch ein Herzenswunsch
in Erfüllung
ja Josef Ratzinger benedikt der 16
gewählt am 19 April 2005 acht Jahre
später zurückgetreten in beiden Fällen
bei Jürgen Erbacher hier in Rom hautnah
mit dabei ist mit ihm jetzt nur ein Jahr
früherer Papst gestorben oder geht mit
Benedikt auch ein Kapitel
Kirchengeschichte zu Ende ich glaube das
mit Benedikt durchaus eine Ära zu Ende
geht sowohl sein Vorgänger Johannes Paul
II als auch er waren bei dem großen
reformkonzil dem Zweiten Vatikanischen
Konzil in den 1960er Jahren mit dabei
jetzt gibt es keinen mehr der das
sozusagen aus erster Hand kennt der in
verantwortlicher Position in der Kirche
ist jetzt kommt die zweite Generation er
war auch wie Johannes Paul II überzeugt
die Kirche muss erneuert werden aber
wenn die beiden an Erneuerung dachten
dann eher an eine geistliche Erneuerung
weniger an strukturellere Formen und
wenn man die Debatten in der ganzen Welt
in diesen letzten Jahren auch sieht dann
wird immer mehr der die Forderung nach
strukturellen Reformen auch laut also
hier sieht man auch eine Veränderung
gegenüber dem was in den jahrz davor war
die Forderung nach strukturellen
Reformen die natürlich vor allem in
Benedikt Heimatland in Deutschland
besonders laut ist und auch das
Verhältnis zwischen Benedikt und seinen
Landsleuten geprägt hat wir sind Papst
so hat ja die Bild-Zeitung am 20 April
2005 für die Wahl von Josef Ratzinger
zum ersten Papst seit 1523 vermeldet an
der Schlagzeile die ja schon kurz danach
Kultstatus erlangte insgesamt drei Mal
hat Benedikt seine deutsche Heimat
während seines Pontifikats besucht und
dabei bleibende Botschaften hinterlassen
19 April 2005 weißer Rauch kündet von
der Wahl des 265 Papstes der
Kirchengeschichte
kardinale 13 Jahre
Josef Ratzinger in Deutschland hatte in
kaum einer auf der Rechnung 23 Jahre
lang Chef der römischen
Glaubenskongregation in seiner Heimat
gefürchtet als strenger Lehrmeister wird
er sich zum Guten Hirten wandeln
die Kardinäle haben mich gewählt einen
einfachen und bescheidenen Arbeiter im
Weinberg des Herrn
die erste Auslandsreise führt Benedikt
nach Deutschland zum Weltjugendtag in
Köln Josef Ratzinger der Gelehrte auf
dem Stuhl Petri als umjubelter
Menschenfischer Benedikt Ansprache mit
gleichsam zur Kernbotschaft seines
Pontifikats nur sondern hier nicht die
Ideologien retten die Welt sondern
allein die Hinwendung zum lebendigen
Gott der unser Schöpfer der Garant
unserer Freiheit der Garant des wirklich
guten und waren ist
Authentico gott ist die Liebe diese
Botschaft überrascht seine Kritiker in
Deutschland statt des moralischen
Zeigefingers betont der deutsche Papst
die sanften Seiten der katholischen
Lehre Nächstenliebe statt doch mal im
September
2006 zieht es den Papst aus Bayern in
seiner Heimat in München wird er von
150.000 Menschen begrüßt der Münchner
Marienplatz ein Ort mit großer
Symbolkraft für den früheren Erzbischof
von München Freising es ist für mich
tief bewegen wieder auf diesem
wunderschönen Platz zu Füßen der
Mariensäule zu stehen an einem Ort der
für mich zweimal Zeuge entscheidender
Wendepunkt in meinem Leben war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit einem Gebet an der Mariensäule hatte
Josef Ratzinger knapp 30 Jahre zuvor
seinen Dienst als Münchner Erzbischof
begonnen hier hatte er sich
verabschiedet kurz bevor er in den
Vatikan wechselte als perfekt der
Glaubenskongregation
im katholisch geprägten Eichsfeld im
Norden Thüringens erfüllt sich Benedikt
einen lang gehegten Wunsch hier will er
jene stärken die in Zeiten der
Unterdrückung der Kirche die Treue
gehalten haben zwei Gottlosen Diktaturen
ist darauf Anliegen den Menschen ihren
angestammten Glauben zu nehmen waren
sich die Eichsfelder gewiss hier
Nordrhein eine offene Tür und eine
Stätte inneren Friedens zu finden
als erster Deutscher auf dem Stuhl Petri
seit fast 500 Jahren hat Josef Ratzinger
Geschichte geschrieben auch in seiner
Heimat
[Musik]
ja Papst Benedikt und seine deutschen
Landsleute ein durchaus schwieriges
Verhältnis dass wir jetzt noch einmal
ein bisschen vertiefen wollen mit
Daniela odowski der Bundesvorsitzenden
der katholischen landjugendbewegung
guten Morgen guten Morgen als Josef
Ratzinger zum Papst gewählt wurde waren
sie erst 12 Jahre alt welche
Erinnerungen verbinden sie mit dem
deutschen Papst also ich kann mich schon
noch sehr bewusst an die Papstwahl
erinnern und zum Beispiel den
Weltjugendtag in Madrid und ganz
allgemein an ein Papst der sehr für die
traditionelle katholische Kirche
eingestanden ist ähm meine würde ich
sagen brings Erinnerung war auf jeden
Fall der Rücktritt des Papstes den ich
als großen Fortschritt wahrgenommen habe
dass die katholische Kirche doch mal
Dinge anders macht Ämter ablegt und
macht trotzdem ein Papst der infragen
von Sitte und Moral auch Sexualmoral
durchaus ja eine strengere Linie hatten
lassen wie leicht oder schwer war es für
sie als engagierte junge Katholiken sich
in der Gemeinde zu engagieren und auch
dieses Engagement gegenüber anderen zu
vertreten unglaublich schwierig also
gerade Papst Benedikt hat
abgelegt die katholische Sexuallehre zu
lockern und ich glaube hat damit vor
allem für junge Menschen dafür gesorgt
dass die Kirche immer realitätsferner
wurde und es deswegen natürlich auch
total schwierig gemacht sich in der
Kirche zu engagieren und ich glaube
spätestens als dann die Missbrauchsfälle
öffentlich wurden und wie Papst Benedikt
damit umgegangen ist war für uns total
schwierig sich dann weiter in der Kirche
zu engagieren und Papst Benedikt ja hat
sich glaube ich immer für die
Verteidigung des Glaubens und der Kirche
eingesetzt aber wir hätten uns viel
stärker gewünscht sich für die Menschen
und für die Betroffenen einzusetzen hat
das auch die Katholische Jugend in
Deutschland ein Stück weit gespalten
aufgespalten eben sagen wir mal
Traditionalisten Anhänger dieses Papstes
aber auch Gegner oder sagen wir mal
Kritiker also ich glaube schon dass
gerade auch die Landschaft der
Jugendlichen auch sehr divers ist ähm
ich bin aber schon der Meinung dass es
viele junge Menschen gibt die Reformen
wollen und es geht gar nicht so sehr ums
wollen sondern dass wir die auch
brauchen was ist denn Jürgen aus der
Anfang des Euphorie dieses Jahr nach
2005 gab es eigentlich geworden was hat
diesen Papst am Ende seinen Landsleuten
entfremdet
ich glaube das Verhältnis zu Josef
Ratzinger war für die Deutschen immer
ein herausforderndes Verhältnis ja auch
schon in der Zeit als Kardinal über 20
Jahre perfekte glaubenskommunikation
auch da man hat immer mit ihm gerungen
das ist aber auch ein Ausdruck dieses
gesamtränens zwischen Rom und der
deutschen Kirche des erleben wir auch in
diesen Tagen unter franziskus wenn man
an den Besuch der deutschen Bischöfe im
November denkt die Reformen auf der
einen Seite Rom sagt ja aber nicht
vielleicht so wie ihr euch das vorstellt
ich glaube Josef Ratzinger ist da ein
Beispiel dafür wie schwer sich
Deutschland mit rumtut und Rom mit
Deutschland könnte es denn für Papst
franziskus jetzt leichter werden
Reformen wirklich umzusetzen da jetzt
quasi kein in Anführungsstrichen
Schatten ein paar Vatikan sitzt was
glauben Sie also ehrlich gesagt bin ich
schon noch ein Stück weit unsicher ob
jetzt nach zehn Jahren franziskus der
Tod von Benedikt dazu führt dass wir den
großen Aufbruch sehen den wir uns glaube
ich so lange wünschen und den wir auch
unbedingt brauchen Papst sonst hat er
selbst gesagt dass er Benedikt als den
Weisen Großvater gesehen hat er noch mit
im Haus ist ich glaube schon dass ich
ein Stück die Dynamik ändert ob das
ausreicht für den großen Aufbruch weiß
ich nicht und ich glaube dass jetzt
unglaublich wichtig ist welche Art von
Erinnerungskultur wir auch an den Tag
legen schaffen wir es auf der einen
Seite respektvollen Menschen zu
verabschieden aber auf der anderen Seite
eben auch kritisch und mutig auf das zu
schauen was sein Amt hinterlassen hat
wenn es eine Region gibt in Deutschland
in der in diesen Tagen ja wahrhaft
getrauert wird um den Verstorbenen Papa
emiritus dann ist es sicher Bayern und
speziell München wo Josef Ratzinger ja
vier Jahre Erzbischof war und wo er 2006
bei seinem Bayern Besuch als Papst
umjubelt wurde Stefan leifert steht auf
dem Marienplatz in München Stefan die
begleiten die Münchner Papst Benedikt
heute auf seinem letzten Weg
ja das wohl wahrnehmbarste Zeichen der
Trauer das ist das Glockengeläut was
nachher um 11 Uhr in ganz Bayern auch
hier auf dem Münchner Marienplatz als
Andenken an Papst Benedikt zu hören sein
wird ansonsten es gibt keine
öffentlichen Übertragungen in den
bayerischen Bistümer der Beerdigung
heute aber viele Diözesen haben Fahrten
nach oben angeboten so dass heute
mehrere hundert Gläubiger aus Bayern
auch live auf dem Petersplatz dabei sein
werden in aller früher hat sich eine
bayerische Delegation auf den Weg
gemacht unter Leitungen Präsident Söder
sind insgesamt 170 Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter aus Bayern dabei heute live in
Rom das wohl markanteste Zeichen des
Abschieds das hat hier schon
stattgefunden das war das Requiem
vorgestern abend hier in der Münchner
Liebfrauenkirche da hat Kardinal Marx
natürlich den großen Kirchenlehrer und
Theologen Josef Ratzinger gewürdigt aber
auch die Schattenseiten angesprochen und
von Versagen gesprochen im Kontext des
Missbrauchs die Geschichte zwischen den
Bayern und diesen Papst ist eine mit
Schulen und Tiefen der emotionale
Höhepunkt sicherlich die umjubelte
Deutschlandreise ein Heimatbesuch hier
in Bayern von Papst Benedikt die hier
begonnen hat an der Münchner Mariensäule
die man hier hinter mir sieht eine
Mariensäule die viel mit dem Leben von
Benedikt und Josef Ratzinger zu tun hat
hier der sich 1982 auch von den
Münchnerinnen und Münchnern nach Rom
verabschiedet der Tiefpunkt sicherlich
letztes Jahr die Vorstellung des
Münchner missbrauchsgutachtens dass den
damaligen Erzbischof von München Josef
Ratzinger ja auch persönliches
Fehlverhalten attestiert hat dass er
sich dafür nie entschuldigt hat dass er
nie persönliche Verantwortung übernommen
hat das hat hier in Bayern und vor allem
im Erzbistum München tiefe Wunden
hinterlassen und eine Enttäuschung die
sicherlich auch zu diesem Tag und zum
Blick der Bayern heute nach oben gehört
soweit die Eindrücke aus der bayerischen
Landeshauptstadt danke Stefan leifert
während hier sie haben es gesehen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer der Einzug
bereits begonnen hat Papst franziskus
hat bereits Platz genommen wird ja
dieser Totenmesse für Benedikt den 16
vorstehen ein Requiem das mitkommentiert
wird von Pater Maxx Bianca ich grüße sie
hallo wenn wir mal kurz auf die Liturgie
schauen wie unterscheidet sich diese
Totenmesse von einem Requiem für einen
ja regulären nicht im irritiert
tatsächlich sind jetzt die Gebete
angepasst worden damit die deutlich wird
dass sie sich nicht um eine Regierenden
Papst handelt interessant auch das
andere Lesungen ausgesucht wurden das
Evangelium ist jetzt das wo jesus stirbt
und sagte in Jesus Vater in deine Hände
gebe ich meinen Geist also ein sehr
berührendes Evangelium und am Schluss
fällt weg ein Gebet der Kirche von Rom
und der orientalischen Patriarchen das
ist also ein so die wesentlichen
Unterschiede zu leben letztens von
Johannes Paul dem zweiten
Benedikt hat sich ja eine schlichte
Zeremonie für heute gewünscht inwiefern
wird dieses Requiem das wir gleich
erleben auch diesem wunschgerecht
tatsächlich entspricht diese Messe
eigentlich einem ganz normalen Requiem
es ist nichts hinzugefügt am Schluss
gibt es eben die Aussegnung
musikalisch haben wir gesehen es ist
auch ganz einfaches Programm von daher
ist diese Bitte Rechnung getragen worden
gut dann werden wir jetzt das Bild und
das Wort Freiräumen für den Beginn
Gottesdienstes kommentiert von Jürgen
Erbacher und Partner max
eröffnet
Brüder und Schwestern
damit wir die heiligen Geheimnisse in
rechter Weise feiern können wollen wir
bekennen dass wir gesündigt haben
es folgt das Schuldbekenntnis
lasse uns die Sünden nach und führe uns
zum ewigen Leben Amen
[Musik]
und Gemeinde Singen im Wechsel jetzt das
Kühe herr erbarme Dich ein Bekenntnis
das Gott und der Herr ist und zugleich
eine Bitte um Erbarmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lasset uns beten
[Musik]
Gott in deiner Vorsehung hast du deinen
Diener unseren Papst Benedikt zum
Vorsteher deiner Kirche auserwählt
dein Sohn
Stellvertreter er auf Erden war nehme
ihn auf in die ewige Herrlichkeit
darum bitten wir durch Christus Christus
deinen Sohn und sein Herrn und Gott denn
der Einheit des Heiligen Geistes mit dir
lebt und herrscht in alle Ewigkeit
es folgt nun die Lesung aus dem Buch
Jesaja
der libre oder
so spricht der HERR bitte der Töpfer wie
tun geachtet sagt denn das Werk von dem
der es herstellt er hat mich nicht
gemacht
und ein Topf von seinem Töpfer er
versteht nichts
nur noch eine kurze Zeit dann wandelt
sich der Libanon in einen Baumgarten und
der Baumgarten wird als weit gelten
die Tauben werden an jenem Tag die Worte
des Buches hören und das Dunkel und
Finsternis werden die Augen der Blinden
sehen
die gedemütigten freuen sich wieder im
Herrn und die Armen unter den Menschen
jubeln über den Heiligen Israels
[Musik]
der Kantor singt den Antwort Psalm
Psalm 23 der Herr ist mein Hirte
der Psalm drückt das Vertrauen des
Glaubenden auf Gottes Führung aus
auch wenn ich gehe im finsteren Tal ich
fürchte kein Unheil denn du bist bei mir
[Musik]
der Christen drückt sich das Vertrauen
auf das ewige Leben in den Fersen aus ja
Güte und Schuld werden mir folgen mein
Leben lang und heimkehren werde ich ins
Haus des Herrn für lange Zeit
[Musik]
es folgt die zweite Lesung aus dem
ersten Brief des Apostels Petrus
gepriesen sei der Gott und Vater unseres
Herrn Jesus Christus
er hat uns in seinem großen Erbarmen neu
gezeugt zu einer lebendigen Hoffnung
durch die Auferstehung Jesus Christi von
den Toten
zu einem unzerstörbaren makellosen und
unvergänglichen Erbe das im Himmel für
euch aufbewahrt ist
Gottes Kraft behütet euch durch den
Glauben
damit er die Rettung erlangt die am Ende
der Zeit offenbart werden soll
deshalb seid ihr voll Freude
wenn es für kurze Zeit jetzt sein muss
dass er durch mancherlei Prüfungen
betrübt werdet
dadurch soll sich eure Standfestigkeit
im Glauben die kostbarer ist als Gold
das im Feuer geprüft wurde und doch
vergänglich ist herausstellen
Herrlichkeit und Ehre bei der
Offenbarung Jesu Christi
[Musik]
nicht gesehen
und dennoch liebt ihr ihn
auch jetzt nicht
aber ihr glaubt an ihn und jubelt in
unaussprechlicher und von Herrlichkeit
erfüllter Freude
da ihr das Ziel eures Glaubens empfangen
werdet eure Rettung
[Musik]
das
Evangeliar das Buch in dem die
Bibeltexte des Evangeliums stehen wird
in einer feierlichen Prozession zum
Hamburg gebracht zu dem Ort an dem es
vorgetragen wird
der Diakon wird das Buch beweihräuchern
ein Zeichen der besonderen Ehre für das
Wort Gottes das in dem Buch
niedergeschrieben ist
schullandgemeinde singen dazu das
Halleluja
[Musik]
denn das ist der Wille meines Vaters
dass jeder der den Sohn sieht und an den
glaubt das ewige Leben hat
[Musik]
der Diakon trägt das Evangelium aus den
Lukas Evangelium vor in italienisch
[Musik]
der andere aber wie sind zurecht und
sagte nicht einmal du fürchtest Gott
dich hat doch das gleiche Urteil
getroffen
[Musik]
uns geschieht recht wir erhalten den
Lohn für unsere Taten dieser aber hat
nichts Unrechtes getan
[Musik]
Jesus denkt an mich wenn du in dein
Reich kommst Jesus antwortete ihm amen
ich sage dir heute noch wirst du mit mir
im Paradies sein
[Musik]
es war schon um die sechste Stunde als
eine Finsternis über das ganze Land
hereinbrach bis zur neunten Stunde
[Musik]
die Sonne verdunkelte sich der Vorhang
im Tempel Riss mitten in zwei und Jesus
rief mit lauter Stimme Vater in deine
Hände lege ich meinen Geist mit diesen
Worten hauchte er den Geist aus
[Musik]
Christus Spiro
Werbung
[Musik]
nach dem Evangelium folgt jetzt die
Predigt von Papst franziskus
deine Hände lege ich meinen Geist schon
die letzten Worte des Herrn am Kreuz ich
hole die muss schon spielen
also könnte man sagen
der das zu bestätigen vermag was sein
ganzes Leben kennzeichnete
ein ständiges sich hingeben in die Hände
seines Vaters
diese Hände der Vergebung und des
Mitgefühls der Heilung und der
Barmherzigkeit diese Hände der Salbung
und des Segens die dazu brachten sich
dann auch in die Hände seiner Brüder und
Schwestern zu geben
Offenheit für die Geschehnisse die ihm
auf sein begegneten den Willen Gottes
auferlegen indem er alle Konsequenzen
und Schwierigkeiten des Evangeliums auf
seine schulternahm bis seine Hände die
Wundmale seiner Liebe zeigten
sie meine Hände sagte er zu Thomas und
er sagt dies zu einem jeden von uns
sie meine Hände
verwundete Hände die sich uns
entgegenstrecken und immer fort anbieten
damit wir Gottes Liebe zu uns erkennen
und an sie glauben
in dein Hände lege ich meinen Geist so
lautet die Einladung und das
Lebensprogramm das der Herr ausbricht
und welches das Herz des Hirten wie ein
Töpfer Formen will bis sich in ihm die
Gesinnung Jesu Christi regt
dankbarer Hingabe im Dienst für den
Herrn und sein Volk die sich aus der
Annahme einer gänzlich ungeschuldeten
Gabe ergibt du gehörst mir du gehörst
ihnen flüstert der Herr
du stehst unter dem Schutz meiner Hände
du stehst unter dem Schutz meines
Herzens du bist behütet in meinen
schützenden Händen
ermöglichen es ihm sich in die Schwachen
Hände seiner Jünger zu legen um sein
Volk zu speisen und mit dem Herrn zu
sagen nehmt und esst nehmt und trinkt
das ist mein Leib der für euch
hingegeben wird
betende Hingabe
die sich immer still zwischen den
scheidewegen und Widersprüchen den sich
der Hirte stellen muss und der
vertrauensvollen Aufforderung die Herde
zu behüten herausbildet und verfeinert
wie der Meister trägt er auf seinen
Schultern die ermüdende Last des
Eintretens für andere und der Salbung
für sein Volk vor allem dort wo das Gute
zu kämpfen hat und die Brüder und
Schwestern in ihrer Würde bedroht werden
in dieser Begegnung der Fürsprache
bringt der Herr die Sanftmut hervor die
fähig ist zu verstehen anzunehmen zu
hoffen und alles zu wagen über das
Unverständnis dass dies hervorrufen kann
hinaus
es ist eine unsichtbare und
unbegreifliche Fruchtbarkeit die
entsteht wenn man weiß in wessen Hände
man sein Vertrauen gelegt hat
betendes und anbeten des vertrauen dass
den Hirten Berlin ist was zu tun ist und
sein Herz und seine Entscheidungen den
Zeiten Gottes anpasst
Weiden heißt lieben und lieben heißt
auch bereit sein zu leiden
und lieben heißt den Schafen das
wahrhaft gute zu geben die Nahrung von
Gottes Wahrheit von Gottes Wort die
Nahrung seiner Gegenwart
eine Hingabe die vom Trost des Geistes
getragen wird der ihm bei seiner Mission
immer vorausgeht in dem
leidenschaftlichen Bestreben die
Schönheit und die Freude des Evangeliums
zu vermitteln im fruchtbaren Zeugnis
derer die wie Maria in vielerlei
Hinsicht beim Kreuz bleiben
in jenem schmerzvollen aber starken
Frieden der wieder angreift noch
unterdrückt und in der hartnäckigen aber
geduldigen Hoffnung dass der Herr seine
Verheißung erfüllen wird wie es unseren
Vätern und seinen Nachkommen für immer
versprochen hat
die wir fest mit den letzten Worten des
Herrn und dem Zeugnis dass sein Leben
geprägt hat verbunden sind möchten als
kirchliche Gemeinschaft in seine
Fußstapfen treten und unseren Bruder den
Händen des Vaters anvertrauen
mögen diese Hände der Barmherzigkeit
seine mit dem Öl des Evangeliums
brennende Lampe vorfinden des
Evangeliums dass er während seines
Lebens verbreitet und bezeugt hat
der heilige Gregor der Große lud am Ende
seiner pastoralen Regel einen Freund
dazu ein und forderte ihn auf ihm diese
geistliche Weggemeinschaft zu teil
werden zu lassen und er sagte inmitten
der Stürme meines Lebens tröstet mich
die Zuversicht dass du mich auf der
schiffsflanke deiner Gebete über Wasser
hältst
und dass du mir wenn die Last meiner
Fehler mich niederzieht und mich
demütigt die Hilfe deiner Verdienste
Leistung mich aufzurichten
dies ist das Bewusstsein des Hirten dass
er nicht alleine tragen kann was er in
Wirklichkeit nie alleine tragen könnte
und deshalb weiß er sich dem Gebet und
der Fürsorge des Volkes zu überlassen
dass ihm anvertraut wurde
das gläubige Volk Gottes versammelt sich
es begleitet das Leben dessens der sein
Hirte war
und vertraut es dem Herrn an wie im
Evangelium die Frauen am Grab so eint
uns hier der Wohlgeruch der Dankbarkeit
und der Salbung der Hoffnung und ihm
noch einmal die Liebe zu erweisen die
Liebe die nicht vergeht wir wollen dies
mit derselben Salbung und Weisheit mit
demselben Feingefühl und derselben
Hingabe tun die uns im Laufe der Jahre
zu schenken wusste
wir wollen gemeinsam sagen Vater
in deine Hände empfehlen wir seinen
Geist
Benedikt du treuer Freund des
himmlischen Bräutigams möge deine Freude
vollkommen sein wenn du seine Stimme
endgültig und für immer hörst
soweit die Worte von Papst franziskus
der
über den Hirten gepredigt hat und darin
versucht hat deutlich zu machen wie er
den Verstorbenen als Hirte der Menschen
als Hirte der Kirche
erlebt und verstanden hat
der Aussicht von Franziskus sind
dankbarer Hingabe im Dienst für den
Herrn und sein Volk gewirkt hat
es fangen nun die Fürbitten
wir zu Gott unserem Vater der uns in
seiner großen Barmherzigkeit durch die
Auferstehung Jesu von den Toten neu
erschaffen hat zu einer lebendigen
Hoffnung
[Musik]
für den emeritierten Papst Benedikt der
im Herrn entschlafen ist
möge der ewige Hirte ihn aufnehmen in
sein Reich des Lichtes und des Friedens
[Musik]
französisch
für unseren Papst Franziskus und für
alle Hirten der Kirche mögen sie in
Worten und Werken mutig den Sieg Christi
über das Böse und den Tod verkünden
[Musik]
auf Arabisch für die Verantwortlichen
der Nationen und der internationalen
Organisationen mögen sie sich mit
Weisheit und Weitblick für Gerechtigkeit
und Frieden einsetzen
[Musik]
auf portugiesisch
Brüder und Schwestern die von Armut und
Not in all ihren Formen betroffen sind
möge die Liebe Gottes und öffnen für das
Mitgefühl und für die Gastmannschaft
gegenüber den geringsten und Armen
[Musik]
auf italienisch
für uns die wir hier versammelt sind um
den Sieg über den Tod zu feiern denn
unser Herr Jesus Christus errungen hat
dieser sülgüge Sauerteig der Hoffnung
sein in der Erwartung des Reiches Gottes
[Musik]
gott unser Vater Freund des Lebens höre
das Gebet dass wir im Glauben an den
auferstandenen Herrn an dich richten für
den verstorbenen Papst Benedikt und für
die Anliegen der Kirche und der
Menschheit
an der Gemeinschaft mit dem himmlischen
Jerusalem wo es wieder Traum Trauer noch
Tränen geben wird darum bitten wir durch
Christus unseren Herrn
mit den Fürbitten endete der erste Teil
der Messfeier der sogenannte
Wortgottesdienst
im zweiten Teil steht nun die malfeier
im Mittelpunkt dazu werden die Gaben von
Brot und Wein zum Altar gebracht die
nach katholischem Verständnis dann zu
Leib und Blut Jesu Christi gewandelt
werden
die Schola singt dazu ein Gebet das
traditionell bei Requiem gesungen wird
darin wird für das ewige Leben der
Verstorbenen gebetet
sowie für den Schutz vor den Abgründen
der Hölle Domina Jesu Christa herr Jesus
Christus König der Herrlichkeit
[Musik]
Papst franziskus leitet die Zeremonie
das Requiem da er aber seit vielen
Monaten
durch seine Kniebeschwerden
gehandicapt ist eingeschränkt ist
übernimmt der Kardinal Dekan Kardinal
Reh jetzt die Handlungen am Altar
er zum gaben oration ein
mächtiger Gott Blicke auf unsere Gaben
und nehmen das Opfer an dass wir für den
einen Diener unseren Papst Benedikt
darbringen du hast ihn zum Hohenpriester
in der Kirche bestellt nimm ihn auf in
die Schaden bei dir vollendet sind darum
bitten wir durch Christus unseren Herrn
wir danken dir Vater im Himmel und
rühmen dich durch unseren Herrn Jesus
Christus denn er ist der eine der den
Tod auf sich nahm für uns alle damit wir
im Tode nicht untergehen er ist der eine
der von uns alle gestorben ist damit wir
bei dir in Ewigkeit leben
teilnehmen Morden ohne sajepi
Neon
immer
unosmore diyatus
in gaudio confidentes
[Musik]
durch die Schöpfung und die Gemeinschaft
der Kirche
[Musik]
des Heiligen Geistes auf die Gaben von
Brot und Wein gebetet
Carpus
von der Einsetzung des letzten
Abendmahls
[Musik]
die Gemeinde Preis Tod und Auferstehung
Jesu bisher kommt in Herrlichkeit
[Musik]
wird an das Wirken Jesu erinnert und
dann das Teil dass er an den Menschen
gewirkt und geschenkt hat es wird der
Heilige Geist darauf hören und es wird
in den Anliegen von Kirche und Welt
[Musik]
an dieser Stelle wird besonders für den
verstorbenen Papst Benedikt den 16
gebetet
Simulator
bleibt ähnlich gut
schauen wie du bist ähnlich sein auf
ewig und dein Lob singen ohne Ende
ist
[Musik]
es folgt nun das gemeinsame Gebet des
Vaterunser ein Gebet das der
christlichen Tradition nach Jesus selbst
seinen Jüngern gelehrt hat
[Musik]
hinterlasse ich euch meinen Frieden gebe
ich euch deshalb bitten wir
nicht auf unsere Sünden sondern auf den
Glauben deiner Kirche nach deinem Willen
Einheiten hast
[Musik]
ruft die auf ein Zeichen des Friedens
auszutauschen
der Gesang des agnus-
[Musik]
es ist
eines der ältesten eine der ältesten
Bezeichnungen für die Eucharistie das
Brechen des Bootes in dem
die Jünger
ihren Herrn Jesus Christus erkannten
[Musik]
ihn an verschiedene Ecken des Peters
Platzes um dort dann die Kommunion
auszuteilen
seht das Lamm Gottes das hinwegnimmt die
Sünde der Welt selig die zum
Hochzeitsmahl des Lammes geladen sind
Herr ich bin nicht würdig dass du
eingehst unter meinen Dach aber spricht
nur ein Wort so wird meine Seele gesund
es folgt jetzt hier auf dem Petersplatz
die Austeilung der Kommunion dazu sind
rund 200 Priester und Diakone über den
Platz verteilt damit
die Kommunion die rund 60.000 die
versammelt sind auch gut und schnell
erreichen kann die Schuler sinkt dazu
Psalm 130 die profundis Klammer viate
domine aus der Tiefe rufe ich Herr zu
dir
das ist ein Boos Psalm der traditionell
bei
beerdigungsgottesdiensten gesungen oder
gebetet wird
wende dein Ohr mir zu achte auf mein
lautes flehen
würdest du Herr unsere Sünden beachten
Herr wer könnte bestehen
doch bei dir ist Vergebung damit man ihn
Ehrfurcht dir dient
ich hoffe auf den Herrn es hofft meine
Seele ich warte voll Vertrauen auf sein
Wort
mehr als die Wächter auf den morgen soll
Israel harren auf den Herrn denn beim
Herrn ist die Huld bei ihm ist
Erlösungen Fülle ja er wird Israel
erlösen von all seinen Sünden
aus der Tiefe rufe ich Herr zu dir Herr
höre meine Stimme
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es dauert noch eine Weile bis alle
Menschen alle Gläubigen auf dem
peterplatz Petersplatz die Kommunion
empfangen haben das bietet uns die
Möglichkeit
Benedikt den 16
noch einmal selbst sprechen zu lassen
Texte von ihm zum Tod zur Auferstehung
[Musik]
seine Ansprache von Papst Benedikt der
Messe zum Gedenken an dem vergangenen
Jahr verstorbenen Kardinäle und Bischöfe
am 3 november 2012
aber wie antworten wir Christen auf die
Frage des Todes
die Antworten mit dem Glauben an Gott
mit einem Blick der festen Hoffnung die
auf den Tod und die Auferstehung Jesu
Christi gegründet ist
dann ist der Tod auf das Leben hin offen
auf das ewige Leben das nicht eine
unendliche Kopie der gegenwärtigen Zeit
ist sondern etwas vollkommen anderes
[Musik]
der Glaube sagt uns dass die wahre
Unsterblichkeit die wir hoffen nicht
eine Idee eine Vorstellung ist sondern
eine Beziehung der vollkommenen
Gemeinschaften mit dem lebendigen Gott
es ist das Bleiben in seinen Händen in
seiner Liebe es ist das in ihm eins
werden mit allen Brüdern und Schwestern
die er geschaffen und erlöst hat mit der
ganzen Schöpfung
[Musik]
unsere Hoffnung ist gegründet auf die
Liebe Gottes die im Kreuz Christi
erstrahlt und im Herzen die Worte des
Guten schächers erklingen lässt heute
noch wirst du mit mir im Paradies sein
das ist das Leben des zu einer Fülle das
zu seiner Fülle gelangt ist es ist das
Leben in Gott ein Leben das wir jetzt
nur erahnen können wie man den klaren
Himmel durch den nebelarmt
[Musik]
bei der bei der Messe zum Gedenken an
die im vergangenen Jahr verstorbenen
kardinell und Bischöfe im Jahr
sagte Benedikt XVI
[Musik]
aus der Perspektive der Weisheit des
Evangeliums heraus trägt der Tod selbst
eine heilbringende Leere in sich
denn er zwingt uns der Wirklichkeit ins
Auge zu schauen
er drängt uns die Vergänglichkeit dessen
zu erkennen was in den Augen der Welt
groß und stark erscheint
[Musik]
angesichts des Todes wird jedes Motiv
für den menschlichen stolz bedeutungslos
während das was wirklich zählt deutlich
zu Tage tritt alles ist endlich
wir alle sind nur vorübergehend auf
dieser Welt
Gott allein hat das Leben in sich er ist
das Leben
[Musik]
derselben Ansprache im 3 November 2018
sagte Benedikt Bibel Brüdern Schwestern
dieses Wort des Lebens und der Hoffnung
ist uns ein tiefer Trost angesichts des
Geheimnisses des Todes besonders dann
wenn die Menschen die wir am meisten
lieben davon betroffen sind
der Herr versichert uns dass unsere
Verstorbenen aus dem Tod in das Leben
hinübergegangen sind denn sie haben sich
für Christus entschieden haben sein Joch
das nicht drückt auf sich genommen und
haben sich den Dienst an den Brüdern und
Schwestern geweiht
[Musik]
auch wenn unsere Verstorbenen ihren Teil
der Strafe der durch die menschliche
Schwachheit bedingt ist die uns alle
zeichnet uns dabei hilft demütig zu
bleiben sühnen müssen können sie durch
die Treue Christi in die Freiheit der
Kinder Gottes eingehen
wenn also der Abschied von ihnen uns
Trauer bereitet hat und ihr fehlen uns
immer noch Schmerz zufügt so erfüllt uns
der Glaube innerlich mit Trost bei dem
Gedanken dass ebenso wie bei Jesus dem
Herrn der Tod keine Macht mehr über sie
hat
[Musik]
ist nur die Seele treten
indem sie in diesem Leben durch das
barmherzige Herz Christi
hindurchgegangen sind sind sie in Gottes
Ruhe eingegangen wie es im Buch der
Weisheit heißt und jetzt stellen wir Sie
uns gern in der Gemeinschaft der
Heiligen vor endlich befreit von den
Bitterkeiten des Lebens und doch wir
verspüren den Wunsch und eines Tages
dieser so glücklichen Gemeinschaft
anzuschließen
[Musik]
wenn wir hier gerade die Krippe auf dem
Petersplatz sehen die Geburt von Josef
Ratzinger lag seiner Zeit geprägt
im an Ostern
dem zentralen Fest der Christen der Tod
nun in der Weihnachtszeit
in den beiden größten geprägten Zeiten
sie
sind Anfang und Ende
des Lebens von Josef Ratzinger
[Musik]
der Leichnam wird
nachher in den Grotten des Petersdoms
bei gesetzt
dieser Teil wird privat sein er wird
dann nicht mehr von den Kameras
begleitet
am Ende des Gottesdienstes gleich nach
der Kommunion wird franziskus
den Sarg mit Weihwasser besprengen und
beweihräuchern
es werden noch mal Gebete gesprochen die
anempfehlung des Verstorbenen
an Gott
dann wird der Sarg in den Petersdom
getragen und dann in den Grotten
beigesetzt
viele der Priester die die Kommunion auf
dem Platz ausgeteilt haben sind schon
wieder zurückgekehrt
in diesen Tagen ist in Rom Weltkirche
spürbar geworden
[Musik]
sind auch sehr viele junge Priester sehr
viele Ordensleute nach Rom gekommen um
von Benedikt dem 16 Abschied zu nehmen
im Heftchen das an die
teilnehmenden verteilt wurde ist
tatsächlich jetzt ein Moment der Stille
vorgesehen bevor dann das schlussgebiet
den Gottesdienst den eucharistischen
Teil abschließt und es dann zur
Aussegnung kommt
lasst es uns bieten
ein mächtiger Gott wir haben die Gabe
deine Liebe empfangen erbarme dich
deines Dieners unseres Papstes Benedikt
auf Erden war er ein treuer Verwalter
deiner Geheimnisse nimm ihn auf in deine
Herrlichkeit damit er dich Preise in der
Gemeinschaft der Heiligen darum bitten
wir durch Christus unseren Herrn
der Gottesdienst schließt jetzt nicht
mit dem Segen ab sondern es folgt die
Aussegnung und Verabschiedung des
Verstorbenen
Geheimnisse haben wir unseren Geist und
unsere Herzen geöffnet für die Seele
Hoffnung mit dem gleichen Vertrauen
entbieten wir papstem mehrere plus
Benedikt den letzten großen dem
barmherzigen Vater der groß ist dann die
Liebe
der Gott unserer Väter Gewehre bei Papst
der meritus Benedikt durch Jesus
Christus seinen eingeborenen Sohn im
Heiligen Geist der Herr ist und lebendig
macht ihn vom Tod erlöst im himmlischen
Jerusalem zu loben in der Wartung der
Auferstehung seines Leibes am letzten
Tag
die selige Jungfrau Maria die Königin
der Apostel und das Teil des römischen
Volkes drehte beim ewigen Vater der
Verein dass er seinen Papst ernährt dass
Benedikt das Angesicht seines Sohnes
Jesus schauen lassen und die Kirche auf
ihrem Weg durch die Zeit Herrlichkeit
der Papst besprengt nun den Sarg mit
Weihwasser und in zensiert ihn mit
Weihrauch das Weihwasser erinnert an die
Taufe der Weihrauch Erd die Kostbarkeit
des Leibes
die Schuler singt eine Art
Glaubensbekenntnis Credo Quad
redemptomeus ich glaube dass mein
Erlöser lebt darin kommt die christliche
Hoffnung zum Ausdruck dass alle Christen
an der Auferstehung Christi Anteil haben
werden
[Musik]
tatsächlich
vollzieht diesen Ritus Kardinal Reh der
kardinaldekan
das Laufen wäre für Papst franziskus
wohl doch zu mühsam
[Musik]
Papst franziskus wird nun noch ein Gebet
sprechen
gütiger Vater Deiner Barmherzigkeit
vertrauen wir unseren Papst im eritus
Benedikt an den du zum Nachfolger Petri
und zum Hirten der Kirche bestellt hast
zum unerschrockenen verkündigen eines
Wortes und zum treuen Verwalter deiner
göttlichen Mysterien
wir bitten Dich nimm ihn auf in die
heiligen Städten des Himmels wo er sich
mit all deinen Auserwählten an der
ewigen Herrlichkeit erfreuen möge wir
danken der Herr für alles Gute dass du
ihm in deiner Güte zum Teil deines
Volkes gewährt hast
gib uns den Trost des Glaubens und die
Kraft der Hoffnung
ihr Vater dem Quell des Lebens sei durch
Christus den Sieger über den Tod im
Leben spendenden Geist alle Herrlichkeit
und Ehre von Ewigkeit zu Ewigkeit
nun folgt in paradisum zum Paradies
mögen Engel dich geleiten
[Musik]
nun ist der Gottesdienst an sein Ende
gelangt ist der sagt dass er den Papstes
wird nun zum Ort der Beerdigung gebracht
und dabei wird das Magnificat gesungen
der Lobgesang Mariens meine Seele preist
die Größe des Herrn und mein Geist
jubelt über Gott meinen Retter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Benedikt du treuer Freund möge deine
Freude vollkommen sein wenn du die
Stimme des Herrn endgültig und für immer
hörst so hat Papst franziskus in seiner
Predigt dem Verstorbenen Benedikt im 16
zugerufen und dessen sagt ein einfacher
zypressenholztag wird nun also in diesem
Augenblick angehoben von den 12 Trägern
und in die Petersbasilika hineingebracht
für den letzten und dritten Teil der
Feierlichkeiten nämlich das eigentliche
Begräbnis in den vatikanischen Grotten
[Musik]
Kardinäle sind Benedikt vorausgegangen
sozusagen sie sind schon in den
Petersdom hinein das Kardinalskollegium
ja dieses Kollegium das einen Papst
wählt und das sozusagen zum engsten
Beraterkreis zum engsten
Mitarbeiterkreis eines Papstes Zelt
Applaus für den Verstorbenen der
deutschen Papst Benedikt den 16
zu dessen Beisetzung viele Gläubige
geistliche Bischöfe aus Europa speziell
Deutschland angereist sind und die ihnen
nun auf seinen letzten Weg begleiten
[Musik]
Papst franziskus berührt in holzag
seines Vorgängers segne die noch einmal
ob der Pontifex im Anschluss tatsächlich
an der Beisetzung im kleinen Kreis in
den vatikanischen Grotten teilnehmen
wird hat der Vatikan offen gelassen
es wird in jedem Fall eine Beisetzung
unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit an
der nur wenige Kardinäle teilnehmen
werden
ein dank der bayerischen Gläubigen die
vor allem in der Amtszeit Benedikt
zwischen 2035 und 13 ja immer wieder
hier auf dem Petersplatz gekommen sind
und wie wir sehen auch eine erste
Forderung nach einer baldigen
Heiligsprechung Santo solito
der langjährige Vertraute und Sekretär
von Benedikt dem 16 hatte ja in den
vergangenen Tagen auch schon in einem
Interview gesagt es könnte durchaus sein
dass heute bereits auf solche
Forderungen laut werden
die Wahrnehmung das haben wir ja im
Laufe der Sendung immer wieder auch
gesagt ist sehr unterschiedlich was
Benedikt den 16 anbetrifft und viele
sehen in ihm einen großen Lehrer der
Theologie und des Glaubens und drücken
das durch santosubito aus
[Musik]
nun also verlässt Benedikt XVI
das Licht der Öffentlichkeit könnte man
sagen sein Sarg in schwindet
im Petersdom und von dort geht es dann
hinab in die vertikalischen Grotten
dort wird dieser zypressenholztag noch
einmal in einen zinksack gegeben der
dann verschweißt und mit Segeln versehen
wird
und dieser zinksack wiederum wird dann
in einen weiteren holzsack gelegt werden
der dann schließlich in die Grablege
hinabgelassen wird und zwar genau an der
Stelle an der vor gut 17 Jahren Papst
Johannes Paul der zweite zur letzten
Ruhe gebettet wurde ganze in der Nähe
des Petrus Grabes
ja ein Requiem geht zu Ende Jürgen
Erbach hat das sicherlich nicht so ganz
zu vergleichen ist mit dem großen take
wie im für Johannes Paul den zweiten im
Jahre
2005 was wird dir in Erinnerung bleiben
gut der Unterschied sind ist die Anzahl
der Gläubigen was die Liturgie selbst
anbetrifft da es vieles von dem
geblieben weil der Vatikan ja eben auch
wollte und klar signalisieren wollte
hier ist ein Papst verstorben der
Unterschied war ja dann am Ende das
nicht die Gebete der Kirche von Rom der
Ostkirchen noch mal folgten ich denke
wir haben es gesehen es war eine sehr
schlichte und einfache Feier
die Musik die Gregorianik die Josef
Ratzinger benedikt der 16 liebte hat
diesen Gottesdienst geprägt und ich
glaube es war ein sehr würdiger Abschied
für einen Papst und ich denke in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen werden wir
jetzt dann in eine Diskussion auch
einsteigen was die Wertung dieses
Pontifex anbetrifft eine Wertung die
vielleicht sogar erst nachfolgenden
Generationen vorbehalten bleibt wenn wir
Frau dowski mal auf diese Totenmesse
schauen die sie als junge Katholiken
hier hautnah miterleben durften was hat
sie besonders beeindruckt in der
Zeremonie also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen dass für mich hier vor Ort zu sein
gar nicht so einfach war hier der
Trauerfeier zu folgen weil ich doch ganz
deutlich gesehen habe wie wenige
Menschen hier vor Ort waren und vor
allem auch sehr deutlich wurde wer dann
die Personen sind die vorne am Altar
stehen wie männlich geprägt diese Kirche
ist und wenn dann der schwenkt der
Kamera durch die Menge ging war doch
deutlich dass diese Kirche eigentlich
viel bunter ist viel diverser viel
jünger als wir oben auf dem Podest eben
sehen und ich finde das als junger
Mensch noch mal irgendwie sehr schade er
hier vor Ort zu sehen wer denn die
Menschen sind die dann diese Kirche aber
sehr öffentlich vertreten obwohl wir
eigentlich die Werte sind als es jetzt
hier auch heute zu sehen war wir glauben
Sie denn wird benedikt der 16 am Ende
die katholische Kirche vor allem auch
junge Menschen geprägt haben wir wissen
dass die Kirche gerade in Deutschland
aber in ganz Europa natürlich auch unter
Nachwuchsmangel leidet sowohl bei dem
Priestern als auch letztlich bei den
Gläubigen selbst die kirchenlehren sich
immer mehr konnte er da etwas
Nachhaltiges etwas Bleibendes seiner
Kirche in Deutschland schenken also ich
glaube natürlich dass auf der einen
Seite Papst Benedikt ein sehr starkes
Bild der Kirche nach außen präsentieren
wollte und eine triumphierende Kirche
ich glaube gerade im Lichte dessen was
wir jetzt wissen ist es total wichtig
eben kritisch auf seinem Amtszeit zu
schauen und natürlich neben der
Theologie und neben all den sicherlich
auch Errungenschaften der für diese
Kirche vorangebracht hat eben ganz
kritisch drauf zu schauen was müssen wir
aus diesem qualifikat lernen und was
sind eben einfach die Schlüssel die wir
daraus ziehen müssen und gerade wie als
junge Menschen die diesen Aufbruch so
unbedingt möchten ist denn zu befürchten
Jürgen dass es am Ende doch so er hat
einen Streit so etwas wie einen Streit
um die Deutungshoheit geben wird der
sich in den letzten Tagen auch zum Teil
schon angedeutet hat wo gerade auch die
Anhänger Josef Ratzingers ja zum Teil
sehr dünnhäutig reagieren die Kritik
natürlich auch sehr laut war vielleicht
auch nicht immer stilvoll war im Sinne
des dem Motto ist die nächste bene
nichts schlechtes über Tote zu sagen das
ist muss man sagen auch nicht unbedingt
berücksichtigt worden droht so ein
Streit um das Erbe benötigt ich weiß
nicht ob es ein Streitwert oder ob es
nicht einfach eine Debatte wird ein
Diskurs und ich glaube dazu ist dann
auch ein solches Werk da wie Josef
Ratzingers uns hinterlassen hat das eine
das theologische ich glaube wir sind ja
auch ganz viele unterschiedliche Ebenen
reden wir über das theologische Werk
reden wir über die Frage auch was den
sexuellen Missbrauch anbetrifft auch da
muss man sehr differenziert schauen ich
fand es interessant eine Stimme der der
deutsche Kirchenrechtler Schüler der vor
wenigen Tage sagte wir müssen mal gucken
wir müssen warten bis die Archive da
sind um z.B auch die Rolle von Josef
Ratzinger wirklich bewerten zu können in
seiner Zeit auch als perfekt es gab
enorme Widerstände die spüren wir ja
auch bis heute noch in manchen Teilen
der kirchlichen Hierarchie und da
sozusagen anzufangen etwas zu verändern
ich glaube es wird eine Weile brauchen
bis man auch wirklich seriös darüber
diskutieren kann ob das jetzt Streitwert
Polemik gut ist auch in Kirchenkreisen
immer wieder mit dabei aber ich glaube
man muss es ruhig angehen und muss auch
glaube ich noch ein bisschen Zeit
verstreichen lassen deshalb ist auch so
bei der Frage nach Santo subito da hat
man auch bei Johannes Paul dem zweiten
glaube ich gelernt da muss man einfach
sagen Leute lass uns jetzt wollen wir
Ihnen begraben in Würde und dann atmen
wir durch und dann schauen wir drauf und
dann wird das natürlich auch Kritik
geben aber dann muss man wirklich seriös
miteinander reden bei Johannes bei dem
zweiten waren die Santos sowieso auch
schon am Tag des Requiems zu sehen und
zu hören das hat dann weitere sechs
Jahre bis zur Seligsprechung gedauert
und noch einmal drei Jahre sprechung wir
werden sehen wie sich das bei Benedikt
dem 16 entfaltet gerade eben hat die
Glocke hier 11 Uhr geschlagen und das
ist der Moment an dem in ganz
Deutschland und vielleicht hören Sie es
auch liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
zu Hause die Kirchenglocken läuten
darauf haben sich die deutschen Bischöfe
verständigt das in allen 27 Diözesen des
Landes nun also Glockengeläut erfolgen
soll im Gedenken an den Verstorbenen
Benedikt den 16 und deswegen fragen wir
doch gleich mal Stefan leifert der für
uns in München auf dem Marienplatz ja
aus hat Stefan wie haben die Münchner
sozusagen Benedikt auf seinem letzten
Weg begleitet
ja hier in München werden gleich wie in
Bayern und in ganz Deutschland alle
Kirchenglocken läuten in Erinnerung an
Benedikt soweit ist es noch nicht ganz
wir haben jetzt kurz vor elf aber das
wird eine sehr beeindruckende
Geräuschkulisse sein hier auf dem
Münchner Marienplatz mit der Mariensäule
im Mittelpunkt vor der Benedikt als
Papst und als Bischof oft gebetet hat
und 2006 hat er hier sein Deutschland
sein Bayern Besuch begonnen hier an
dieser Mariensäule vor der er sich auch
verabschiedet hat damals als Erzbischof
von München als er dann als perfekt nach
oben geht was bleibt in Bayern von Papst
Benedikt von Josef Ratzinger es sind
drei Dinge das eine ist sicherlich die
Erinnerung an und der Stolz auf einen
großen Kirchenlehrer auf ein großen
Theologen ja eine jahrhundertfigur der
katholischen Kirche und eine Figur die
mit Bayern seiner Heimat immer sehr sehr
eng verbunden war daran hat er nie
Zweifel gelassen zweitens bleiben ganz
viele ganz konkrete Erinnerungen an
diesen Papst Kulturen Bildnisse Benedikt
sollen an vielen Orten die mit ihm
verbunden sind zum Beispiel Regensburg
München Altötting oder auch sein
Geburtsort Marktl jetzt beginnt das
Leuten hier die Frauenkirche beginnt zu
Leuten das ist die Erinnerung an diesen
Papst und das Gedenken an Josef
Ratzinger was bleibt drittens drittens
auch eine gewisse Distanz die es Zeit
des Lebens von der Josef Ratzinger immer
gegeben hat zwischen den Gläubigen auch
hier in Bayern und Josef Ratzinger
selbst eine Distanz die sicherlich am
größten wurde als letztes Jahr das
missbrauchsgutachten der Münchner
Erzdiözese erschienen ist und ihm ganz
persönlich auch Fehlverhalten attestiert
hat im Umgang mit den Missbrauch hier in
der Erzdiözese München was auch an
Distanz bleibt ist das Befremden über
diesen erzkonservativen Kirchenmann in
vielen kirchenpolitischen fragen wie
sexual Moral oder oder auch Frauen
Ordination Benedikt seinerseits hat die
deutschen hat die bayerischen Katholiken
immer für zu verwählt Licht gehalten und
umgekehrt hat es dann zurückgeschaltet
dass dieser Papst einfach ein
weltfremder sein also auch diese Distanz
auch dieses ernüchterne denken und
Gedenken an Papst Benedikt das wird
bleiben und gab es zu Lebzeiten schon
und wird auch dessen Tod überdauern auch
in diesem Moment wo sich Bayern hier an
Josef Ratzinger mit dem feierlichen
Geläut in ganz Bayern erinnert
[Musik]
von 1977 bis 81 war Josef Ratzinger also
Erzbischof von München Freising auch
eine Zeit an die sich die Münchner und
die Bayern speziell am heutigen Tag des
Requiems erinnern werden sich hier in
Rom der Petersplatz so langsam lehrt
denn das was jetzt geschieht der dritte
Teil der Feierlichkeiten nämlich die
eigentliche Beisetzung vollzieht sich
unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit in
den vatikanischen Grotten und vielleicht
kurz Gelegenheit einmal wir haben ein
paar Bilder vorbereitet zu schauen in
diese vatikanische Krypta unterhalb des
Petersdoms gelegen dort wo er einige
Dutzend papstgräber gelegen sind wo
eigentlich alle Päpste der jüngeren Zeit
auch tatsächlich beigesetzt sind genau
also es war ja an der Stelle vorher
Johannes Paul der zweite bei gesetzt vor
dem vor dem Johannes der 23 also alles
Päpste die auch mit dem Zweiten
Vatikanischen Konzil in Verbindung
stehen mit
reformkonziel es ist sage ich mal einer
der üblichen Plätze an der an dem Päpste
beigesetzt werden in den Kotten von St
Peter gibt auch einige die oben im Dom
selbst beerdigt sind weil ein Papst hat
eigentlich das Anrecht hier in der Nähe
des Petrus Grabes der Papst ist ja der
Nachfolger des Apostels Petrus nach
katholischem Verständnis deshalb auch
das Anrecht hier in der Nähe des Grabes
begraben zu sein und in den Sack
Benedikt sind gestern Abend schon einige
Grabbeigaben gelegt worden unter anderem
Münzen aber auch eine Schriftstück das
wie ich gelesen habe die wichtigsten
Stationen ja nicht nur seine spontifikat
sondern eigentlich seines Lebens
wiedergibt genau das wird in so einem
Metallgefäß gegeben dass wenn die
Nachwelt mal den SAG öffnen sollte dass
man weiß okay wer war dieser Papst und
was waren so die wichtigsten Stationen
seines Lebens aber auch seines
Pontifikats da wird zum Beispiel erwähnt
dass er drei entzücklingen geschrieben
hat da wird erwähnt
dass er Jesus Bücher geschrieben hat
weil die Frage nach Gott wach zu halten
den Menschen diesen Jesus von Nazareth
nahezubringen aus sich derer die dieses
Dokument verfasst haben eine der
zentralen Punkte war da wird auch der
Kampf gegen den Missbrauch erwähnt ich
denke da wird auch noch eine Debatte
darüber und brennen wie diese
Formulierung so gewählt wurde das werden
manche kritischer sehen als es da steht
und es wird der spektakuläre Rücktritt
erwähnt weil das ist natürlich auch
etwas was für dieses Pontifikat steht
und was für Josef Ratzinger steht ich
habe übrigens in einem Gespräch dieser
Tage gehört dass er sogar schon in den
ersten Tagen des Pontifikats in
Äußerungen deutlich gemacht hat dass so
etwas möglich sein kann in einem sehr
privaten Kreis und von daher muss man
sagen für ihn war der Schritt vielleicht
am Ende gar nicht so groß wie für das
Umfeld weil er die Perspektive immer
hatte das kann auch lebend zu Ende gehen
dieses Pontifikat manche
Kirchenhistoriker diesen Rücktritt ja
jetzt schon oder vergleichen ihn mit dem
Fall der Berliner Mauer als wirklich
einschneidendes Erlebnis als Zäsur in
der Geschichte des modernen papstturms
eine Zäsur die möglicherweise natürlich
auch die Nachfolger prägen könnte auf
franziskus der Jahr diesen Schritt
Benedikt schon mal als großes Beispiel
geräumt hat gut ich glaube für
franziskus ist vor allen Dingen in
sympathisch dass mit diesem Rücktritt
das papstland etwas papstland etwas
entzerkalisiert wurde geerdet wurde
menschlicher gemacht wurde ich sag jetzt
mal etwas salopp obwohl das viele
Theologen ist auch nur ein Job also ist
nicht ganz vergleichbar aber so nach dem
Motto hier ein bisschen geerdet und das
ist natürlich franziskus sehr
sympathisch wie es jetzt bei ihm steht
wird der Druck jetzt vielleicht sogar
größer dass er zurücktritt weil
sozusagen der Mann gebrochen ist oder es
gibt andere die sagen er darf jetzt auf
keinen Fall zurücktreten weil sonst wird
quasi eine Selbstverständlichkeit und
die nächsten paybacks bekommen und einen
großen Druck also diese Geschichte des
Rücktritts ist noch nicht so ganz zu
Ende geschrieben und auch die Frage in
ihren Auswirkungen aber diese Sache mit
dem geerdet auf jeden Fall
Auswirkungen auch auf das partifikat von
Franziskus der am 13 März übrigens
dessen sozusagen Wahl zum Papst sich am
13 märz zum 10 Mal wird also wir haben
auch hier schon ein Pontifikat das
länger dauert als das Pontifikat seines
Vorgängers Stichwort Hirten hinter mir
etwa 100 Meter hinter mir steht meine
Kollegin Annette hilsenbeck und hat
diesen Trauergottesdienst auch aus
nächster Nähe mit verfolgt Annette ja in
welcher Stimmung in welcher Atmosphäre
in welcher Anteilnahme haben die
Gläubigen diesen letzten Weg Benedikt 16
begleitet
und gerade zum Ende zu hat man ja
gesehen dass es doch eine starke
bayerische Delegation hier gab also in
starke deutsche aber auch eine starke
bayerische Delegation hier gab die noch
mal zum Schluss ihren Gruß ihren
Abschied an Benedikt den 16 geschickt
hat das Bayerische Pilgerbüro hat ja
mehrere Busse Sonderbusse gechartert um
den Gläubigen die Möglichkeit geben
hierher zu kommen unter anderem ist hier
Pfarrer Matthias Kienberger aus
Alteglofsheim in der Nähe von Regensburg
der mit einer Gruppe hier ist guten Tag
wie wie warm war ihnen das ein
besonderes Anliegen hierher zu kommen
ich persönlich habe sehr viele
Erinnerungen an Papst Benedikt dem 16
ich war damals in Regensburg außer
gewählt wurde 2005 beim Rücktritt
2013 2012 vor euch hier mit einer Gruppe
und es war so beeindruckend ich kenne
ihn auch vom Studium her hier in Rom ich
habe da drüben im Campus handelt
und habe den Sprachkurs italienisch
gemacht und hat er Donnerstag mit uns
die Messe gefeiert und wir konnten dann
anschließend mit dem Frühstücken das war
immer so schön ihn in seinem Dialekt
reden zu hören so herzlich so
aufgeschlossen war er uns gegenüber und
das all dies ist heute wieder
hochgekommen und deswegen war es mir ein
großes Anliegen hierher zu kommen mit
einer Gruppe wie haben sie denn nun das
Requiem empfunden
es war eine sehr gesammelte Stimmung
hier von Petersplatz ich war im Bereich
wo die ganzen Priester waren es war
Stille es war so andächtig die Leute
waren so mit dabei die waren ganz
hingerissen auch davon von dem
Gottesdienst selber und es ist so
manchen ein Schauder über den Rücken
gelaufen wegen der ganzen Erinnerungen
an den Benedikt an die Zeit in Bayern
sein großartiger Besuch 2016 Regensburg
gemacht hat all dies ist wieder
hochgekommen
ja vielen Dank wir merken also eine
besondere Verbundenheit
besteht hier und Respekt und Dankbarkeit
für das Lebenswerk von Benedikt dem 16
ja danke Annette Trauer und spürbare
Anteilnahme natürlich vor allem unter
den bayerischen Gläubigen gegenüber
ihrem Papa im eritus der am Silvestertag
im Alter von 95 Jahren gestorben ist und
der sich aber doch immer wieder auch
gezeigt hat auch in den letzten Jahren
zuletzt übrigens noch mal auch für die
Öffentlichkeit sichtbar wurde im August
letzten Jahres nach dem Papst franziskus
neue kardinelli kreiert hatte und er mit
diesen 20 neuen kardinellen dann ins
klostermaterial in den vatikanischen
Gärten kamen damit ähm Benedikte
Gelegenheit hat die neuen Kardinäle noch
einmal zu begrüßen kennenzulernen die
Papst Wähler der Zukunft könnte man
sagen Jürgen denn diese Kardinäle werden
natürlich auch nach dem Tode von
Franziskus im Konklave seine Nachfolge
wählen
ja das stimmt allerdings und das haben
wir ja auch schon gesagt dem Vatikan ist
wichtig ein Papst ist gestorben aber der
Papst lebt und regiert von daher bis zum
nächsten Konklave ist sicher noch einige
Zeit hin gibt uns Gelegenheit noch eine
weitere Perspektive mit den die
Nachbetrachtung dieses Pontifikats zu
holen und zwar von Peter Seewald dem
langjährigen Biographen und man könnte
auch sagen publizistischen Begleiter von
Josef ratzäcker denn beide haben mehrere
gesprächsbände herausgegeben besonders
bekannt geworden Salz der Erde über das
Christentum an der Schwelle zum 21
Jahrhundert meine Kollegin Barbara luke
hat mit Peter Seewald über das Erbe
Josef Ratzingers gesprochen
Interview mit einem der ganz nah dran
war vertraut mit Ratzinger über 30 Jahre
ein intimer Kenner papstbiograph
es gab unzählige Gespräche unzählige
gemeinsame Stunden ein Gedanke hat ihn
bis heute niemals losgelassen das war
der eine Satz auf ihn fragte der
Kardinal wie viel Wege gibt es
eigentlich zu Gott und er musste da gar
nicht lange überlegen und ich habe
wieder gesagt na ja vielleicht nur den
einen den katholischen oder den
christlichen oder wie auch immer nein er
sagt es gibt so viele Wege zu Gott wie
es Menschen gibt sie haben so viel Zeit
mit ihm verbracht wir haben sie ihn als
Mensch erlebt was war vielleicht ein
besonders schöner Moment mit ihm also
wir haben viel Zeit miteinander
verbracht aber mit ihm konnte man nicht
sich abends nochmal irgendwie auf einen
Whiskey zusammensetzten der konnte nicht
anders leben als das was er lernt das
war eins ja also denken sagen tun das
war eine Linie und er hat viel auch mit
seinem mit seinem Humor wird gemacht
also er konnte er war zum Beispiel
begeisterte ein großer Fan von
Karl Valentin und er konnte also Sketche
von dem Spielen und also es war ein
Vergnügen mit ihm zusammen zu sein
wenngleich was auch immer heftig harte
Arbeit war ja
der Hardliner der auch humorvoll sein
konnte für Außenstehende schwer zu
glauben wie Peter Seewald diesen Spagat
empfunden hat
natürlich war er jemand der unbequem war
ja Ratzinger war jemand der auch um den
Preis der Popularität gesagt hat
es geht hier um
Grundfesten des katholischen Glaubens
die verteidigt werden müssen dazu bin
ich bereit haben sie in die hadern mit
der Kirche erlebt
zweifelnd also mit der Kirche ist
hart ins Gericht gegangen also
unvergesslich sein großes Herz nur als
Kardinal wo er am Karfreitag 2015 sagte
so viel Schmutz gibt es in der Kirche
und gerade unter solchen die ihres
Priester ganz zugehören sollten also die
Missbrauchs der große Missbrauchskandal
was sicher etwas was ihn am meisten
bewegt hat
Gedanken Schriften Zweifel Visionen im
Spiegel eines langen denkwürdigen Lebens
was wird bleiben für die einen wird er
sicherlich weiterhin also der
personifizierte Rückschritt sein aber
ich schließe mich da eine Mutter gern
Papst franziskus an das Vermächtnis
Benedikt wird für die Zukunft der Kirche
unverzichtbar sein und es wird von
Generation zu Generation größer in
Erscheinung treten aber natürlich ist
immer davon ab was die Menschen daraus
machen
so blickt Peter Seewald an diesem Tag
auf ihn
[Musik]
ja Barbara Look im Gespräch mit dem
Biografen und Publizisten Peter Seewald
der auch oft hier in Rom war auf dem
Petersplatz der sich nun hinter uns sie
sehen ist so langsam lehrt am Tag des
Requiems der Beisetzung von Benedikt im
16 der vermutlich in diesem Minuten in
den vatikanischen Garten zur letzten
Ruhe gebettet wird was auch bedeutet das
Papst Franziskus von nun an der einzige
ist der im Vatikan weiße Sultane trägt
was glaubst du welche Konsequenzen hat
das jetzt für das Pontifikat und
vielleicht auch ihre Form Bemühungen des
argentinischen Papstes ich glaube für
Papst franziskus ist es noch mal eine
neue Situation er hat zwar nie ein
Zweifel daran gelassen deutlich zu
machen wer Herr im Haus ist aber es war
doch eine eine für ihn glaube ich auch
eine emotionale Beziehung zu Josef
Ratzinger er hat ihn sehr oft besucht er
hat ihn am Anfang auch immer wieder
eingeladen zu Veranstaltungen um den
Menschen glaube ich auch zu zeigen da
ist Kontinuität da bei all den Dingen wo
man sie vielleicht auch unterschiedliche
Akzente setzt und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob sich wirklich sehr viel
verändern wird für franziskus jetzt der
muss es glaube ich auch noch mal neu
finden ich glaube für viele die hier
immer wieder auch versucht haben noch
mal Benedikt den 16 gegen den Papst den
Stellung zu bringen was nie so richtig
gelungen ist für die wird sich jetzt
auch noch mal viel ändern und ich
vermute der franziskus wird jetzt auch
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten schon
auch noch mal schauen was machen wir mit
dem Erbe von Benedikt dem 16 das
theologische Werk aber auch all die
anderen Dinge die er getan hat und da
werden wir sicherlich auch noch einiges
von ihm hören Benedikt 16 am Tag seiner
Beisetzung ja abschließend über seinen
wirken seine Bedeutung für die
katholische Kirche urteilen zu wollen
das wäre sicher vermessen nur so viel
als Theologe wurde er bewundert als
Bischof perfekt und später als Papst
mitunter auch heftig kritisiert in einem
aber dürften sich Anhänger wie Gegner
einig sein mit Josef Ratzinger verliert
die Kirche einen ihrer prägenden Köpfe
der Gegenwart das war unsere
Sondersendung aus Rom danke für Ihr
Interesse und wir verabschieden uns mit
den Bildern des Tages wieder schauen
[Musik]